bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur
rtl vous avez apporté votre soutien à la
famille des victimes vous êtes satisfait
aujourd'hui de l'ouverture de cette
information judiciaire qui vise donc les
deux policiers
c'est une bonne nouvelle après l'épisode
où les policiers avaient été quelque peu
mis hors d'état je dirais mis hors de
cause là-bas du coup le l'enquète et
relancer je pense que c'est important
mois depuis le départ je réclame à ce
qu' il y ait vraiment une justice enfin
ce que les effets et qui sont
extrêmement graves qui se sont déroulées
sur ma commune soit clairement je dirais
clarifier et qu' on puisse avoir tous
les éléments arnal enquête les relances
et je pense que ça c'est important est
certainement que l'avocat de lord signé
pour payer pour beaucoup en tous les cas
le parquet de bobigny a souhaité
remettre en route cette affaire c'est
qu'elle a je pense estimé qu il y avait
quand même des faits assez assez assez
assez assez inquiétant quand même donc
je pense que c'est important pour la
famille c'est important aussi pour
la victime qui est malheureusement
toujours hospitalisés qui risquent de
sortir dans un état assez assez assez
critique parleur il est tant mieux il
est sain et sauf tant mieux que les
policiers aussi de leur côté sont sains
et saufs moi j'ai été très clair dès le
départ je souhaitais qu'il n'y ait voilà
j'ai apporté mon soutien à toutes les
victimes il se trouve que il se trouve
que le conducteur a été celui qui a été
très fortement impacté et moi je reste
quand même assez assez surpris du nombre
d'impacts de balles tirées vers le
conducteur
bon il ya une petite vidéo qui a circulé
elle est sans appel la vidéo on ne peut
pas on ne peut pas dire que cette vidéo
a été a été trafiquée a été montée etc
mais quand on voit la vidéo mais de quoi
se poser des questions sur
l'intervention je dirais très violente
deux enfants tous les cas d'un des deux
pères des deux politiques étaient
présents
lors de cette scène horrible henry pour
le conducteur et puis il faut rossa
alors justement dans un communiqué
publié il ya quelques jours vous
interpeller les autorités sur la
pertinence de l' usage des armes en tout
genre en particulier des armes à feu par
les forces de l'ordre fin de citation
qu'est-ce que vous sous-entendez
je suis en tant que vont
loin de moi de te demander à ce que la
police nationale soit soit désarmé je ne
sais pas ce que je demande mais je pense
que l'utilisation d'armes à feu de mon
point de vue
n'est pas du tout assez assez
réglementée bien évidemment il faut que
les protéger il faut que les policiers
les premiers soient soient protégés mais
il faut aussi en face quand il ya un
accrochage avec la police les individus
soient aussi quelque part protéger et
qu'on se retrouve pas avec cette scène
terrible qui s'est passé a atteint et
qui malheureusement s'est passé aussi
dans d'autres lieux je pense que la
halle il faudrait que le législateur n
est pas je m'adresse à la peau
gouvernement mais aussi au parlement de
revoir l'utilisation des armes à feu qui
de mon point de vue ces dernières années
a clairement établi que l'utilisation
d'armes à feu par la police a
malheureusement conduit à des drames
terribles et n'est pas qu'un seul
l'occasion plusieurs drames qui se sont
déroulés ces dernières années et je
pense que deux secondes ville à la
police qui est une police nationale donc
et une police républicaine doit aussi
s'arroger des lois de la république et
que les policiers certains policiers
bien évidemment ce ne sont pas ce ne
sont pas la majorité des policiers mais
que certains policiers voilà doit pas se
comporter à des ponts pour faire très
court comme comme des comme des cow-boys
problème de formation de certains
policiers des politiques latin tout à
fait je ne cesse de le dire vous savez
moi ça fait des années que je me bats
qui atteint pour que notre commissariat
puisse avoir des moyens de doter des
moyens humains des moyens je dirais
techniques etc et puis aussi des moyens
pour que nos policiers puissent être
formés et je peux comprendre que
certains policiers qui qui viennent de
province
son passage à paris et qui disent on en
région parisienne ou en banlieue on va
venir quelques années pour voilà pour
avoir quelques points et pour être sûr
de pouvoir retourner dans dans la dans
sa région natale je comprends que
beaucoup de policiers et la boule au
ventre quand ils vont quand ils vont au
travail parce qu'ils ne sont pas formés
et parce que il ya aussi besoin d'un
véritable travail d'encadrement et de ce
point de vue là voilà j'invite certains
syndicats qui préfèrent polimiquer
qu'autre chose à se pencher aussi sur ce
sérieux je dirais déficit de formation
d'accompagnement des policiers moi je le
réclame très longtemps et je pense que
des policiers qui interviennent dans des
secteurs les plus difficiles doivent
être formés et puis un vrai travail de
prévention a mené en amont il ya
vraiment un vrai travail mais ça
malheureusement c'est aussi les
conséquences de la politique de sarkozy
encore quelques années qui a qui a
consisté à réduire de manière à thiais
assez forte les moyens de la police si
les moyens de la gendarmerie donc
malheureusement on en paye on en paye
les dégâts aujourd'hui voilà merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation sur arte france à ce débit
j'appelle que vous êtes maire un pcs de
ce temps